hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play condemned okay there's this
mystery here with this arm yeah I don't
know what the deal is it's just kind of
they're holding up something I hear man
yes right one Kaiser ah bird ha three
not bid ha ha give you that Oh what uh
weirdo kind of white trans wait is this
I'm by now
nope okay I don't know what the deal is
with with it but I guess it's not really
nothing no way I don't even know if I'm
in the right place
nope oh here we go ha ha the PAL be
he'll the power of the load no okay
where am I now
oh wait I'm back I'm back here wait
where am I going
I didn't know there's stupid where am I
going
I went up here right didn't I I did mm
hello a peep oh no wait up here all up
here I'm an idiot
alright bloop ah
the signal is getting stronger oh wait
no that didn't that didn't need up that
didn't need that I'm getting a little
overzealous with my fire axe hello hi no
wait a minute
another dead bird for six I'm on a roll
kinda blood booth by this dangler
hey you leave him alone hello oh hi lady
you gonna be okay with me baby all right
okay
oh here no here no here got it kliklak
Oh such a wonderful pose see document a
mannequin in a dead body's okay it's not
quite right looks like you have a male
corpse and a female mannequin wow you're
good
no really Oh Thomas victims face I don't
want to
he's freaky yep just like that she even
color the facial mark is consistent with
the painted marks on all the male
mannequins a previous matchmaker crime
scene oh this is strange
Thomas gash on his right hand while he's
missing a finger gotta do everything
around here taking pictures
photographer our cup shut
yes yes oh yes yes guys the matchmaker
oh okay
he certainly didn't kill himself and set
it up this way no fine with my uber
investigate oh hello
I didn't expect to be right there on his
neck damn no usable DNA trees Oh must've
worn gloves what is it too early to call
small particles that show up as a
potential organophosphate pesticide oh
that didn't look like it would have
killed him but whatever hey about it no
yeah that cop shouldn't have come in
here with like no backup that kind of
sucked for him
I mean how did he get jumped on by this
guy I've been cleaning these guys out by
the score how must be a badass super
out-of-shape cop oh okay nice shot there
Captain Ahab all right Oh take dad -
bull honky - is bull who what's that I
think I've got okay I want to pick up a
gun lady move each of the articles talks
about a serial killer a serial killer
that was on your case list oh nine names
were mentioned
oh those salmon on the nine were crossed
out in each other wait those are the
same faces marker you can't fool me
those week we got same station across
town with a matchmaker and the torturer
those are duplicate faces that were
crossed out
gone cold - hold on man the matchmaker
wait are you implying that there's
someone stalking serial killers like
tickle stairs around killing killers and
then he marks off their name in his
little personal diary yes no it doesn't
sound too harshly nor buy it adds up it
almost makes sense hello good renamed
[ __ ] listen my a story backs a what done
well that seemed normal huh two shots my
favorite I'm so happy I have to come
everybody I got a present for it yep
about yeah what's that you want some too
well I got one more shot with wayward go
oh they are hey come back here I just
want a dog with you I just want to talk
with you how are you Arthur
oh I'm out of bullets shells so what now
but no oh no oh
block
say you love me I'll just kill him
good lordy Lou God oh that's not good
man lordy Lou Karen the you'd think that
the back that the butt end of a shotgun
would kill a man dead but it takes like
what what uh hell yeah - call me back
yeah sure what is a G the fingerprint
and the metro station and the boot print
are not the matchmakers but this other
guy so is he the torturer uh-huh it's
not the torturers think about it
a final murder in each of those cases on
your list ended with a killing similar
to the previous one okay this guy goes
around and kills the dealers in the same
way that they're doing the innocent yeah
uh-huh
I told her that you got to do like
Dexter
so this serial killer X kills serial
killers yeah he takes them down using
their own methods
if the torturer is still at large what's
his MO pretty sex stuff he likes to
abduct people
Luca doll Deb you know his goal is to
drive them to suicide so he doesn't
actually deliver the final blow
what is this city coming to alright so
I've got to find the torturer and save
his ass so the new killer doesn't kill
him you don't have to do that I mean
come on man you've been on a merger
agent apparently sorry we can't find out
so public information and I have
something else you need to say oh come
to the bureau yeah and then meet me at
the city library oh you know there's
been a fire there things shut down for
repairs oh oh exactly there's damage but
there's got to be a terminal or two
still working and no one will know right
can you meet me there in 15 minutes I'm
not gonna make it in that time Oh she'll
be there all right so these really dead
birds right here that I can get hmm yes
I wanna fight with a locker door you
kidding me give me those give it a loo
too bad hello it didn't matter just
Christmas here ah hello
oh yeah
luck Mouse unlock silver detective
achievement badge yeah I knew I could do
it Oh
laughs yeah there God I got a door jeez
what was that yeah I know Oh double
whammy
hey I got no you do too too bad
Oh double shine Oh double kill for the
hell oh I'm such a badass what the hell
Oh Cho give me that yeah Oh what oh no
oh you give me that get to it I'll take
that thank you very much hold on boom
thank you or shoddy shooties I love when
I'm full on well we're getting reports
of violent outbreaks um someone who's
known these Barb's okay don't tell me
what to do Lee hey another piece of
metal the pieces of metal are actually
easier to collect than I thought I just
need to keep an eye out for the eyes
also I need to not be on a level where
everything's given to me right away
nice mattress famous cubby yeah it seems
what how did he lose hi hey there little
kid seriously how did he lose you like
God nine shots in the guy I don't know
what is the city coming to dead bird my
favorite double whammy double whammy
curse you were just shooting at him a
second ago
there we go thank you
hi sir I'm bummed I'm phoned hon lock oh
yeah
what now oh my god oh god don't what the
hell is that I are dead that did not go
any very well I don't like guns very
much they're not effective given
point-blank shotgun it's it's not
effective that bird
thank you see where am I supposed to go
picking up a bike god dammit the friggin
fog did you come from
yes please do that I'm going out here
don't hit me don't hit me those pills
give it give it not you with that lock
the door I'm gonna punch come on punch
get out you don't know please show I get
on my way I take it out of my way I need
to get over here okay can I just kill
you thank you
ah now kill me no come on ready for you
now
your ugly face get shout
okay gonna jump whoa what's up ah you
know know what I thought why why is this
effective heist how did that catch on
fire
what is happening nope thank you
just a random dumpster ride out of
nowhere that makes sense what the hell
was that
yeah they wouldn't have noticed it if
your cracker cracker anything like that
where are you Rosa be quiet really
really copper really yeah I got a look
at the door the door that's cracked
halfway over
hey smithy Johnson wait up ha ha real a
still there very few people can tell me
to shut up and get away with it oh yeah
sorry I'll be there a couple minutes I
don't think I could protect you anyway
so anyway I'm all out of time oh kinda
almost there not enough time to start
again because there's gonna be the
interest of how do I miss two birds
a [ __ ] feels like ah dude I don't even
say all right probably I was like man
I'm alright I'm so thank you so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always
we'll see you in the next video bye